[Music]
I'm excited why I'll tell you why it's
big news big big celebrity story today
Justin Bieber turned 18 today you know
what that means he can now be tried as
an adult
oh he's gonna pay
watch yourself Justin here
no juvie for you he's 18 he'll be voting
tonight some contract yeah
legally binding with no adult
supervision he's gonna get crazy no I
really do want to start that's a nice
story but I really want to start the
monologue on a positive know something
what I'm sure we have some Americans in
the crowd wow I never thought there
would be that many huh
don't you know it's euro night here at
Kona this is a very positive story
yesterday and if you heard about this
the u.s. beat Italy in soccer for the
first time ever
true yeah America hasn't embarrassed
Italy this badly since the first Olive
Garden opened which I am
[Applause]
it's my angry Italian guy
Jimmy's vino doesn't like that one
so many Italians in that band MIT Romney
of course you know he said he's having
us try he's you know he's winning these
primaries but he's having a lot of
trouble connecting to the common voter
to the common person just regular folks
so he's trying a little too hard in an
interview yesterday MIT Romney said that
he has worn a garbage bag as rain gear
he said that and said I've worn a
garbage bag as rain gear
yeah Romney said it was easy all I had
to do was dump out the hundred dollar
bills and throw the bag over his head
[Music]
he's in here they're everywhere and and
ironically it was raining money yeah
that's my new thing now to be mad at you
for no reason your new thing yeah going
on 20 years of that like hey alright
settle down
nibble on your shirt why don't you yeah
Arnold Schwarzenegger and Maria Shriver
are reportedly seeing a couples
counselor in an attempt to save their
marriage yeah
when asked to comment Arnold said that's
not what I meant by a threesome he
always eats a sausage that's what that
was by the way
he always has an Austrian sausage king
in my impression that's the actress
choice that I made crazy story but it's
true listen to this
a man in Albuquerque has registered his
dog to vote yeah
apparently the dog likes the current
administration but he's just not sure he
wants another 28 years of Obama
[Applause]
yeah okay then yeah we're still like I
don't know what that means
I I think they're just doing the math
yeah a professional wrestler is suing
his opponent after their match resulted
in him losing a testicle yeah
the wrestler still competes but under
his new name Dwayne the missing rock
Johnson
[Applause]
[Applause]
Hey and what's your problem produce
Jeff's like Oh gonna get some soup after
the show that's all he says gonna get
some soup